what up space fam goals in here from
anime up we're back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy chapter of
dragon ball super we got ultra ego
vegito we got bardock goku's dad which i
did not see coming at all so make sure
to stay tuned for this crazy
mind-blowing chapter if you do enjoy
these dragon ball super reviews and want
to keep them coming chill the super
saiyan within and smash that like button
with no mercy remember that smashing is
goku energy and passing is yamcha energy
so choose wisely if you haven't make
this the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future dragon ball super videos and
updates and now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
this chapter is called the fate of the
saiyans and i gotta say i've been loving
the saiyan focus as of late in the manga
dragon ball super hasn't hyped me up
this much with vegeta's new form and
everything else in a really long time we
continue with vegeta and granola
fighting vegeta is definitely on the
defensive as the evolved granola keeps
attacking he keeps going until vegeta
reverts back to his normal form and
granola keeps teasing him which you know
vegeta hates he says no more super
superego or whatever you call it as he
uses vegeta's head as a footstool and
again granola plays the space race card
saying that it looks like fate has
clearly decided that the saiyans are
doomed but vegeta ain't given up yet and
grabs granola's foot to the ladder's
annoyance and says i'm master of my own
fate a pretty epic line and i know that
vegeta is usually cool but still this
line specifically stands out as a banger
vegeta isn't the first to say this the
quote is a tribute to william ernest
henley a british poet and writer but
it's definitely perfect for vegeta whose
ego would not accept anything less
granola though is losing his patience
and keeps wailing on a seemingly
powerless vegeta until goku catches
granola off guard and sends him flying
with a punch i love seeing goku come
help out vegeta like this if vegeta
can't handle it on his own that is and
vice versa if vegeta is helping goku
that's cool too but vegeta pulls a
classic vegeta move and instead of
letting goku take over actually attacks
goku catching his own friend off guard
goku's caught off guard but most of us
fans are not cause we've come to accept
this kind of stuff from vegeta
grinnell's reaction though is great as
he watches vegeta send goku flying and
one hit isn't enough either vegeta says
you take over not if i have a say as he
punches him again he even adds that
there's no one he'd rather beat to hell
and back than kakarot their rivalry has
always been there but goku mistakenly
believes this is an old attitude and
it's not the time for it vegeta though
sets him straight and explains why this
has been his arc so far rather than
goku's he explains that he's only agreed
to fight side by side when they had
something to protect but his life
doesn't count he'd rather lose his life
than team up with goku and that's the
really cool thing about this arc it's
not a situation where bulma and trunks
are in trouble or even the earth vegeta
can truly go full berserk fighter and
it's led to some great moments already
we can appreciate the sentiment but
vegeta actually leaves himself wide open
to be killed and goku has to release a
shock wave that barely saves him from a
mortal wound in time like goku i agree
that there's absolutely no need for
vegeta to die here if he can just take a
break while goku has another go finally
goku reveals some good news now he has a
read on granola's whole targeting vitals
thing and can avoid taking lethal damage
in time granola thinks this is a joke
and hits goku to the point he drops
reversed to his normal form granola
feeling pretty good about himself begins
to walk away thinking goku is helpless
to fight after that but goku quickly
resumes blue form and sends an attack
that catches granola off guard granola
tests out if it was a fluke but goku
keeps shifting his vitals out of harm's
way and can actually land hits on
granola that sent him flying back
granola still feels confident for his
part though since with this strategy
goku is mainly on the defensive and he
can't see goku being able to launch
attacks that can take him out and goku
himself admits that this could be a
problem with the smile on his face
absolutely love how goku meets
challenges like this with a smile on his
face rather than with frustration vegeta
then comes to and witnesses some
exchanging of blows between goku and
granola but it seems to be of no use
granola lands a hit and afterwards goku
reverts to his base form once again
surprisingly early in his turn goku
acknowledges that his body won't last
much longer and shockingly vegeta
confidently asserts that he's tagging in
and he actually looks up to it based on
his expression that is vegeta blames his
saiyan pride for his stubbornness and
desire to win alone and mentions that
since granola just learned to unleash
this side of his power he won't last
long and granola actually does look
really tired even more so than vegeta at
the moment vegeta is banking on granola
hitting his limit and he'll take
advantage of it when it happens and go
for the win goku agrees and just tells
vegeta not to die for us vegeta fans who
want to see vegeta get the w here
there's definitely been plenty of vegeta
greatness already and great to see him
coming in once more and getting another
chance to win this this has definitely
been his battle more than goku so far
and i honestly would love it to stay
that way but we'll see what happens
vegeta then starts playing with granola
mentally stating that his drive for
revenge has rotted his brain he thinks
he's only alive for revenge and that
there's nothing more to live for one of
the reasons vegeta can read granola so
well is because he was also in the same
boat in the past whether he wanted
revenge against frieza or goku he can
probably imagine exactly what granola is
thinking vegeta even eggs granola on
asking him to hit him with everything he
can muster and then once more he
transforms to ultra eagle vegeta i'm as
surprised as granola that vegeta can
keep this up but i'm definitely not
complaining granola says vegeta's hit
his limit but vegeta reiterates that
this power is unbounded and has no
limits vegeta is now definitely the one
on the offensive and as he hits granola
close to the city granola begs to take
the battle elsewhere showing that he
clearly isn't that single-mindedly
focused on revenge as he thought since
he's still trying to protect the city
and the civilians you gotta love how
vegeta even resorts to chomping down on
granola's arm that he was using to try
and punch him not exactly refined
martial arts technique but fun to see
vegeta go so animalistic vegeta reveals
that he's been strategic and brought him
to the city so that granola couldn't use
his rapid fire attacks however in such
close range he's sure the city will be
fine and he unleashes point blank
attacks at vegeta despite what he
thought the attacks did reach some
buildings as they begin to crack vegeta
is in base form again and even granola
has reverted to a previous form as his
second eye is back to normal and he's
panting like he's about to drop any
second as he lays down to rest for a
second the window behind him cracks
revealing some traumatized citizens
granola is beginning to realize that
he's in a way become like the saiyans
that destroyed his own city despite the
motive his battle is leading to a
repetition of history and this time he's
not the victim we see a really cute kid
granola running to his pretty mother in
a flashback as they embrace suddenly
something frightens them and it's
implied that she died thanks to
destruction caused by the saiyans now
just as he was cowering in fear with his
mom he sees these new sugarians doing
the same and this time he's brought on
their fear vegeta bless him gets up
again this dude has been extraordinary
this arc he really has and he's sounding
pretty rational here he says that the
grudges against the saiyans are well
deserved and he won't object to granola
destroying him but wouldn't granola
eradicating the saiyans just be
repeating history so vegeta has pretty
much said what we've been observing
history is clearly repeating itself with
all the destruction and innocent people
suffering again thanks to granola's
fight against the saiyans granola tries
to hold on though to his revenge and
screams that their planet was always
peaceful and then the saiyans took
everything from him so he can't move
past that ever he unleashes more damage
on vegeta now vegeta must be in really
bad shape and to make matters worse
granola is ready to burn away the rest
of his life force here aka he'll shave
his remaining life and put it into a
super powerful attack for us it's so
obvious how stupid this is frieza is the
only one who may deserve this attack and
yet granola is going to use it on
frieza's enemies before he ever even
gets a chance to get revenge on frieza
but it serves to show us how blinding a
thirst for revenge can be especially
when it's this blind and poorly
calculated for instance in the katamati
crystal the revenge is much more
satisfying and well planned here
granolas is poorly planned and more
hysterical than anything else his attack
looks huge and powerful though
definitely enough to finish vegeta off
again he says his revenge on frieza will
have to wait for the afterlife which
shows how ridiculous his whole mission
is as he prepares to meet his death
vegeta isn't afraid or angry he handles
it like a boss smiling and even
apologizing to lord beerus that he
wasn't able to cut it he's willing to
accept this as the fate of the saiyans
if it must be like this and although
this seems to be a contradiction to his
i am the master of my fate line it's not
really in the sense that vegeta is
choosing how to act in the face of death
and to meet it head on rather than
kicking and screaming and resisting it
no one has 100 control over external
events or what happens to them but they
do have control over how they react to
what happens and you can see that in
practice here with vegeta and he's
definitely acting like a boss goku
realizes that they are both willing to
die and wants to stop them and then
granola's namekian friend appears he's
shocked to see goku and that will be
explained pretty soon the namekian sees
the insanely powered up attack and
finally he tells granol to knock it off
granola is shocked to see his friend and
for a second it knocks him out of his
revenge obsessed mind state long enough
for goku to tackle him thus again goku
saves his bro vegeta and you gotta love
vegeta's reaction goku just saved his
life and all he gets is a smirk and
from vegeta in the meantime granola is
mad at monato for interfering and you
can see that granola is tormented the
search for revenge as a life's purpose
is clearly not a happy way to exist in
utter anguish he screams out that he
just wants it to end he needs it to be
over finally monaeto drops the most
shocking thing of the chapter he
explains that granola can't generalize
with saiyans because even then there was
one saiyan who didn't earn his vengeance
40 years ago the one who saved them was
bardock we all know as goku's dad and
then a shocked granola repeats that
hussein was actually their savior
showing just how idiotic and
oversimplified granola's revenge against
all saiyans was but i think for all of
us we're just so excited to see bardock
being brought back into the story
bardock is some of my favorite dragon
ball material and i did not expect them
to be brought into this arc but we may
well get some bardock flashback now and
i cannot be happier about that first
vegeta's amazing new form and now
bardock this arc of dragon ball super is
amazing in my view and i'm enjoying it
much more than the moral arc personally
but as always let me know your thoughts
on this chapter and what you are most
looking forward to happening next for me
it's definitely bardock and let me know
who your mvp was this chapter if you're
asking me it had to be vegeta for just
constantly getting up time after time
and for the way he was ready to
stoically accept his own end vegeta has
been glorious this arc no doubt anyways
if you do enjoy seeing these dragon ball
super reviews and want to keep them
coming you know what to do channel the
super saiyan within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember that
smashing is goku energy and passing is
yamcha energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
dragon ball super videos and updates and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
so
[Music]